welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka definition and
this episode were breaking down the
ending of depths the series has been one
of the best things that I've watched in
recent memory and the final entry has a
lot to unpack from it throughout this
video we're going to be going over the
ins and outs of the season as a whole
and giving our thoughts on it
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to check it out
yeah and don't want to know what happens
then I highly recommend that you turn
off now there is no way to back out as
the universe has already decided that
you will watch this so so yeah anyway
with all out the way thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
our breakdown of depths this is your
station I'm not going to tell you don't
worry you're gonna figure it out
okay so dev centers around a tech
company called Amaya the company is
named after the daughter of the CEO who
tragically died years prior and this is
shaped the business into developing
certain things that is an namely machine
that can predict the future and render
images of the past with near accuracy
due to it possessing a wealth of data it
uses these and its complex algorithms to
show the tramlines that the universe is
on and because of its abilities it has
been kept a close guarded secret by the
company I've actually made a full video
breaking down all aspects of the machine
how it works and what its inner
mechanisms are so if you want to know
about that then then pause this video
and go check it out in simple terms
though it basically uses a highly
accurate prediction algorithm to tell
the future since the universe is based
upon cause and effect if one knows the
effects of an action they can trace back
the cause thus telling the past
similarly if one knows the cause then it
can trace the effect there for the
future and it's able to do this because
it understands the laws of nature
perfectly the CEO of Amaya Forrest and
his company have made leaps and bounds
in terms of software and programming but
it's not all sunshine and rainbows due
to their progress they have caught the
attention of several agencies and
governments namely Russia who sent in a
spy named Sergei to run reconnaissance
and the mysterious dabs
Sergey is brought in and sees firsthand
what's going on in the department and he
tries to smuggle out the info but is
captured and killed
Amaya covers up his death and Sergei his
girlfriend Lilly tries to uncover
exactly what's going on
which leads head down the rabbit hole
towards a fate that we've seen teased
throughout the entire season
Lilly turned to her ex Jaime for help
and as she started to discover things
she quickly drew the eyes of Amaya
security guard named Kenton Lilly is the
kind of person to face her problems
head-on and she went to forest directly
and found him with his chief of staff
Katie Katie explained calmly to Lilly
how the machine worked and she told her
that she was destined to attempt to
destroy it which would be an event that
the machine could not see beyond Lilly
decided that she would prove the Machine
wrong and she made a promise to not go
after it
kenton saw this meeting and flew off the
handle because he felt betrayed Lily and
Jamie decided to stay at the former's
apartment until the event was over but
Kenton arrived and killed Jamie he was
just about to kill Lily too but luckily
she was saved by another Russian agent
that had been posing as a homeless man
around the property
Lily was given two choices to either go
to the Machine or flee and prove that it
was incorrect
however she went to a Maia which is
where episode 7 ended
okay so episode 8 starts off with one of
the most trickiest beginnings so far in
it we see Jamie Forrest Amaya and Lily
has a lot of symbolism to it as we see
Lily seemingly split into two and this
becomes important in the finales overall
meaning here Lily comes face to face
with Forrest who explains to her that he
has taken nothing from her as she never
really had anything other than the sense
that she was participating in life now
what this does is that it really speaks
to how he views the death of his
daughter and wife Forrest was clearly an
important element that was paramount in
the cause of their death because he
refused to hang up whilst his wife was
driving I think that this conversation
shows he really refuses to accept any of
the blame and bears no guilt for it
because in his mind it was always meant
to happen that way and he was just a
participant still he has used the
machine to resurrect her in some ways
due to it perfectly recreating her
consciousness
Lily argues that she is a simulation
that is going through fixed motions
before it's rebuff to this by saying
that we all are and thus in some ways we
are all in our own simulations pay
attention to that he has basically
created God in a machine and omnipresent
being that sees and knows all this is
reflected in the name devs which we
actually learn his Deus the Latin word
for God Forrest views himself as a
messiah because he can work the machine
and the series has been laced with
imagery that has painted him out as a
christ-like figure the entire scene is
very off-the-wall and Forrest predicts
her actions as she fulfills them they
watch a version of reality play out on
the screen in which Lily takes her gun
boat's the lift with Forrest and kills
him as they leave the complex the lift
which travels across the vacuum seal is
then dropped and this is how she
eventually ended up crawling across the
the predictions that we saw now it is
important to understand that this is
only a possible future earlier in the
season
Linda discovered that the machine was
full of variables and this is why you
portrayed a scared image however in
removing these variables one was able to
gain a crystal-clear image which was a
possible past though forest states that
the machine knows everything it doesn't
and thus it created scattered images I
used this example of my prior video but
say this image was picked up in the
machine as being a smiley face in the
past in tracing it back it would not
know what color the face actually was
because there are a number of colors
that it could have been however say
someone told it that it was purple it
would strip these away and show the face
as it has been told though the machine
is said to know everything it does not
and even though the multiverse idea was
shut down repeatedly dev subscribes to
the theory in the end as we can also see
a crystal clear image on the screen
during the prediction moment we know
that this is only one possible feature
in which one variable was taken as a
definite and therefore this is only one
possible pathway
I believe that Deb's presents the idea
that there are several options and
pathways that we can all take but
perhaps we have to make the choice to
take them this is exemplified by Lily
who instead of taking the gun with her
on the elevator tosses it to the side
thus of breaking the prediction and
showing that she does have a choice now
what I believe this shows is that we do
indeed have a choice and is possible to
be in control of our own destiny Forrest
was so set on the idea of fate that he
refused to see beyond it because in
doing so he would have to accept that he
was responsible for the death of his
daughter and thus he put his faith in a
get-out-of-jail-free card
that stripped him of guilt because hey
that was the way it was always meant to
happen
he thought that he had a perfect machine
does he brainwashed those around him
into believing that it was perfect -
when really all that it presented were
possible futures the reason that it
couldn't see beyond this is because well
the system discovered that it was in
fact flawed and because this point in
time was wrong it knows that going
forward everything could be wrong and
thus it does not estimate anything
beyond it the elevator still drops
because one of the
variables was the same and Lily
seemingly still comes to an end with
forest Kati is trapped within and Stuart
reveals that he still destroyed the lift
because he finally realized what they'd
done which is created God Lily had
committed the original sin of
disobedience and he saw this and
realized what was going to happen he
blames it on being predetermined that he
would always do that showing that he
still believes in God he exits leaving
Katie trapped within and she returns to
the visualization chamber as we learned
messiahs get resurrected and forest is
recreated in the machine by Katie using
the data collected on him
Katie states that it shows the machine
works but only on linens principle which
means that the multiverse does indeed
exist and everything that we viewed so
far has only been one possible future
forest is reunited with his family
because there is a multiverse and within
the machine exists a possible past in
which they did not perish we are then
taken to Lily who seemingly returns to
her past before Sergey died but she
still retains her memories now in order
to understand this we have to understand
the idea of quantum immortality this
states that if you loaded a gun with one
bullet in six chambers there would be
six branching pathways from this you
would die in one
but it's consciousness ceases upon death
you would instead return in another
universe unaware of what had happened
and believing that you were lucky if you
were to repeat this experiment over and
over you would in some ways gain
immortality because there would always
be a version in which you survived
we saw Linden demonstrate this by
falling off the dam and though we did
not see a version in which the character
survived we do know from the failings of
the machine that there would have been
one it would also be other versions
which lived on perhaps taking different
pathways which Forrest pays lip service
to when they reunite devs sort of takes
this on but instead it reinsert the
consciousness into the machine rather
than letting her live on in the timeline
in which she died this is how she still
retains the memories of everything and
though no one other than Forrest and
Lily know that there within a simulation
it doesn't really matter now she starts
off by replaying the moments that would
have eventually led to her death from
the first episode using sergei spy
encryption Sudoku puzzle she goes to
unlock it but Sergei flips out and she
leaves him to go off on the path
that will eventually lead to his death
because because the girl is cursed I'm
telling you the girl is cursed
instead she returns to the devs
department and actually sees forest
there playing with Amaya and his wife he
explains that this version of their
consciousness is now living out their
hashtag best life and that Lili now has
the option to follow her own path which
we saw demonstrated in a choice with
Sergei there are other versions perhaps
that aren't doing as well but she should
feel blessed the episode ends with Katey
showcasing this simulation to a senator
who wish to know what went on in devs
and they explained that the simulation
can mimic everything and that the ones
inside don't know about it the Senate
asks who else knows about this and she
says no one which which I took is
meaning that we may all or may not be
inside the simulation - Katie says that
she just needs help in keeping it
switched on and in the afterlife Lili is
reunited with Jamie who is still alive
and she gets a happy ending going off
with the man on the path that she should
have stayed on I'm not crying
you're you're crying now we can take the
meaning of the title Deus to be a
shortening of deus ex machina which
means God in the machine as Lily is
someone who's aware of everything being
a simulation and someone that can also
make choices she is a god herself she
too has been depicted as a christ-like
figure at points and she could either be
a new Messiah figure or her and Jamie
could represent the modern Adam and Eve
they have left the Garden of Eden and
can now go off on their own path and
create something within the simulation
that has never been seen before in the
quote-unquote real world there's a lot
to take from it and it's been an
absolute blast to watch and overall I
feel like this was the perfect way to
end it now before we get into the review
of the season I just wanna let you know
we're giving away a free copy of the
Marvel phase 3 part 1 box set to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
be in with a chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the show in the
comment section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of May
and the set will be shipped out from
then - ever gets the prize so best of
luck to everyone who takes part okay so
what did I think of devs as a whole well
I have to say I absolutely loved it from
start to finish it's a series that
initially flew under my radar but I'm so
glad that so many of you recommended
because it was absolutely amazing to
watch what's crazy is that it has a
really similar plot device to West world
right now but both shows took the idea
in completely different directions and
explored it with their own style and a
stake I've always been fascinated by the
idea that there is fate something that
holds the universe together and with
this notion in mind it comforts me and
makes me think that everything will be
okay it's why I absolutely love dr.
Manhattan and something about devs just
makes the idea feel so warm though there
are massive amounts of action dev still
carries itself with its storyline
self-contained narrative and the ideas
that it presents it's near-perfect
and there's very little that I can
actually ding this story for every actor
feels like they've been perfectly cast
and overall it's an incredible ride from
start to finish
I'd love to see more but I don't really
feel like we need it because of the
subtext of the journey that we've just
been on it's rather I give out 10s on
the channel but this is a show that
really feels like it deserves it
dabs is perfect I guess you guessed it
10 out of 10 now obviously I'd loved
hear your thoughts on the season and
what you took from the ending comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and make sure you check out our
breakdown of Westworld which is gonna be
linked at the end we've gone through the
season episode by episode so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want to know more if you want to support
the channel from it's literally the 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early if you want to come check to us
after the show either follow us at
definition whitey or click the discord
link in the description below those are
the best ways to keep up to date with
heavy spoilers so hopefully we see over
there very soon this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
you